[Music]  carlos santana collapses on stage and  gets hospitalized after one of his shows  on tuesday the guitarist was performing  as part of the miraculous supernatural  tour alongside earth wind and fire  [Music]  but at one point during his set santana  passes out and medical personnel rushes  to his side  [Music]  it was reported that the musician was  about 20 minutes into his performance  when he sat down on a drum riser then  fell backward  [Music]  but santana seemed to be in good spirits  clearly conscious and waving to fans as  he was wheeled off stage  and now he's recovering  santana's publicist confirms to et that  the musician was taken to the er for  observation and is doing well turns out  the grammy winner was overtaken by heat  exhaustion and dehydration as for what  this means for santana's future concerts  well his manager announced his show set  for wednesday in pennsylvania will be  postponed to a later date  [Music]